primera cumbre entre eeuu y rusia de la
era byd en una reunión menos
confrontacional de lo que muchos
esperaban y que ambos mandatarios
calificaron como positiva aunque sin
grandes compromisos concretos
cuestionaba ruth en cuanto a la
evaluación general creo que no ha habido
hostilidad por el contrario la reunión
se llevó a cabo con un espíritu
constructivo creo que ambas partes
expresaron su voluntad de entenderse y
buscar formas de acercamiento varios
fueron los temas de consenso se
acordaron consultas sobre ciberseguridad
tras las múltiples acusaciones
estadounidenses sobre presuntos ataques
desde territorio ruso aunque moscú
asegura que la mayoría de estas
ofensivas provienen de eeuu también
acordaron el retorno de sus embajadores
al terreno después de que éstos fueran
llamados a consultas cuando en marzo
baiden llamó asesinó a putin y luego
acusó a rusia de interferir en las
elecciones de 2020 hubo nuevos esfuerzos
para controlar el desarrollo de armas
nucleares una vez concluya el tratado
new start en 2026
no todo fue consenso hubo líneas rojas
en lo referente a la soberanía de
ucrania y al encarcelamiento y salud del
opositor ruso alexéi navalni payden
aseguró que su muerte traería
consecuencias devastadoras para rusia
steitz ningún presidente de eeuu podría
mantener la fe en el pueblo
estadounidense si no habla de defender
nuestros valores democráticos y las
libertades universales y fundamentales
de que todos los hombres y mujeres
tenemos una opinión general
eeuu considera el encarcelamiento de
naval ni una acción antidemocrática para
reprimir la oposición pero para putin es
simplemente una cuestión de derecho
nacional al considerar que el opositor
violó su libertad condicional por una
condena previa cuando fue hospitalizado
en alemania en agosto pasado tras sufrir
un envenenamiento envenenamiento por el
que occidente culpa al kremlin el
encuentro marca una nueva relación entre
las potencias lejanas de la hera trump
la llegada de biden está la relación con
moscú un aire de mayor estabilidad